what are your particular words of advice
regarding the on the occasion of Ramadan
approaching us my advice would be that
every Muslim he or she should make it a
point that they should make a resolution
that they should fast each and every day
of this blessed month of Ramadan and we
should try and acquire all the benefits
of this month and we should not waste a
single minute in this blessed month on
things which are and try and concentrate
as much as possible in Remembering Allah
subhana wa ta'ala we should try and look
for his Mercy we have to try and ask for
forgiveness we have to try and seek for
his love and we have to try and increase
our piety our righteousness and our
patience and our beloved Prophet mmad
Sall wasallam said in
sari ver number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number number 1903 our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallu Ali
wasallam said anyone who does not
leave the false action and false
speech Allah subhana wa ta'ala does not
care if he leaves his eating and
drinking that means if a person does not
abstain from false action and false
speech Allah subhana does not care if
you abstain from food and drink that
means your fasting will not be accepted
unless you stay away from false action
and false speech and a beloved Prophet
mmall Ali wasallam he also said it's
mentioned
in which is written in mus Ahmed R
number two page number 230 Hadith number
7148 and it also appears in sunai
chapter number five Hadith number 21106
where our beloved Prophet mallalli
wasallam said oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching and Allah has ordained for
you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the Devils they will
be
Chained and this month is the
night which is better
than a thousand
months and if a person is deprived of
the blessings in this month he's truly a
deprived person so we have to make it a
point that we gain the benefits of this
blessed
month our beloved Prophet mallam said
it's mentioned s bukari number three in
the book of fasting Hadith number 1
1901 our beloved Prophet mallalli
wasallam
said that that anyone who fasts in this
month with faith seeking the reward of
Allah subhana wa taala all his past sins
will be
forgiven that means if we truly with
sincerity fast in this month and seek
the reward of Allah subhana wa tala all
our past sins will be forgiven imagine
it is such an easy way to have our sins
forgiven of the past and our beloved
Prophet mam also said it's mentioned
sari
volume number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number 1904 this is a
very long Hadith which has basically
Four Points our beloved Prophet malli
wasallam said that all the children of
Adam all the Deeds that they do are for
themselves except for fasting fasting is
for me and I will reward
him and he further said that fasting is
a
shield it prevents you from sin
and the person who observes the fast he
should abstain from
obscenity from yelling and from
ignorance and if someone yells at him or
abuses him he should say I'm fasting I'm
fasting and the third point of beloved
Prophet said in this Hadith is that I
swear by Allah in whose hand is the soul
of Muhammad s wasallam that the breath
of a faster
the person who fasts is sweeter to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala than the scent of
musk and he finally said in this Hadith
that there are two things when a faster
is happy and looks forward to it the
first is when he breaks the Fast and the
second is when he meets the Lord Allah
subhana
tala and further it's mentioned in the
Quran in Sur chapter number 24 verse
number 31 it says or you believe
truly have faith in Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and seek the Bliss that means try
and enter Jah it's mentioned Sur chapter
number
46 verse number 13 and
14 that those are the people who worship
none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and they are steadfast in faith the word
Isam they steadfast in faith that
there's only one Allah and no one else
and they shall not have any fear nor
that shake grief these are the people
who are the people of
paradise and they shall be rewarded for
all the goods they have
done so this is advice for the people
that they should take the best of this
month and should not spend time on
things and spend their time in the
worship of Allah and reming Allah
subhana wa taala and asking for
forgiveness